Let's talk about taboos.
People writing in and saying, should politics
and religion be taboo in conversation with
significant others, with family, with your
significant others, family at work, et cetera?
So the way I grew up was politics and religion
are just like any other topics.
You talk about them with your family, your
immediate family at larger family gatherings,
with friends, etc.
Sometimes there are disagreements, sometimes
there are not.
But assuming nobody is espousing some truly
violent, disgusting position, you talk about
politics and religion just like you do anything
else.
And then everybody still friends and everybody
is still respectful and the like.
I actually now have an even stronger position
on this because online discourse and social
media expose people to political discussion.
That is the worst you can imagine.
I actually think it would be particularly
beneficial for kids from a young age to be
exposed to discussions about politics and
religion that are respectful and that don't
devolve into personal attacks.
Because unfortunately, if at home politics
and religion aren't being discussed, if it's
school politics and religion aren't being
discussed, if wherever else they're not being
discussed.
And the model people have is from.
Twitter, we're really, really screwed.
And people end up not knowing how to peacefully
disagree with each other, how to respectfully
express opinions that aren't the same.
And then just to go back to living with each
other or working with each other, every disagreement
is seen as a personal attack.
People often become triggered.
It's not good.
And we all benefit from talking about our
views and we benefit from having them challenged.
And we benefit from not having topics be off
limits.
Now, this doesn't mean you ignore decorum
or politeness or or don't use common sense.
Right.
If you're on a first date, maybe you do talk
about politics or maybe you don't.
Now, very often politics and religion can
be the difference maker, whether two people
are compatible.
So maybe you do want to talk about it right
away.
Maybe you leave it for the second or the third
date.
I don't know if it's your first time meeting
your significant others parents.
Maybe you skip politics and religion.
That one time, not because you aren't comfortable
discussing it respectfully with whoever.
But simply for for decorum and to avoid disagreements
in the interests of establishing what hopefully
will be a long term relationship.
So use your judgment.
Don't you apply common sense?
I think there's one other element of this
that's important to mention.
Not only are some topics taboo like politics
and religion, but we also have a big deficit
of critical thinking skills and skills with
which we can examine our own beliefs and how
we came to our conclusions.
And I think that if we want to go in the direction
of removing the taboo around talking about
politics and religion where you're, quote,
not supposed to.
We do need people who are better informed
about how to apply critical thinking and basic
epistemology skills.
Overall, though, I think we should be doing
more discussion of topics that often become
emotionally charged, not less.
And there has been no more important time
to be talking about politics and religion
and subjects that can be difficult in all
scenarios.
Of course, again, applying common sense.
If you disagree, let me know.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get a membership almost instantly by signing
up at join Pacman dot com.